Sau hơi 1 năm triển khai nghị quyết sáo tám rau bộ chính trị văn hành.
Kinh tế tên nhân vi nhận nhiều tính hiểu khởi sắc với một chăm sóng chính phải tám
nghị rơi nghiệp hình lần mới.
Và quay lại trong nửa đầu năm hành nghị khủng trong hài sấu.
Cùng với đó, tổng số 1 đang ki vộ xung tăng trường, 1 mùi mùi phép bác phần trăm.
Tạo nên tảng quan trọng trong một tiêu xe dựng mùi hình tăng trường mới và rướng tới
tăng trường kinh tế 2 con số.
Cùng đồng rất nhiều đặc biệt là khối xanh nghiệp nhỏ mà người hợp vẫn đang đối mặt với nhiều điểm ngãn về thi trế.
Tức cận đất đài, vốn và thi trường.
Vì vậy, tôi thảo tập trung làm gió yêu cầu tiếp tục khoảng thiện thiện thi trế.
Các giảm thực chất chỉ có tôn thủ, thảo gửa các giáo cảnh trong mối trường đấu tư kinh doanh.
Đồng thời thúc đầy chuyển tư tư duy quan lý sàng kiến tạo.
Cối xanh nghiệp là đối tác đồng hành cùng nhận nước trong phát triển.
Và là đồng lực chung tâm để giận thức khoảm mục tiêu tăng trường 2 con số.
Còn tâm, thiệt tinh nhất mà người các giảm thực chất đều kịt kinh doanh.
Sôi quanh việc nhận diện những giáo cảnh thi trế còn tôn tài.
Tinh trạng đều kinh doanh bị biến tướng thành các quy trường, tiêu chuẩn tí thuật, phóc tụ tu quen trình mới.
Đồng thời đầy xuất cơ trế giảm sát, nhằm ngán trạng việc phát sinh các giếp con.
Các giảm giả cũng chia sẻ những vấn mắt được thực biển trong các liến vật như tuy sàng, bất đậu sàng.
Và những mạng yêu cầu hoàn thiện thế trế để giảm sì vị tuy thuộc, khơi thông một lực cho gánh nghiệp.
Fíng thứ 2 tập trung vào vai trò của kinh tiền dân trong chiếc lực tăng trường.
Thao lộn các gái pháp, của hích cho khu vực tranh nghiệp thông qua gái thiện môi trường kinh doanh.
Thúc đầy đổi mối sáng tạo.
Thinh thành các doanh nghiệp tuy nhân quy mối lớn, nân cao năng lực thằng ra chủi giả hịp hoàn cầu.
Và hoàn thiện các cơ trế hợp tác công tư để vui động dụng của các một lực phát triển.
Cái hị kiến tại hội thảo thủ nhất rằng để đạt đồng piêu căn trường hải quan sủ,
cả các thị trế cận được chiến khai theo dưỡng thực chất, chuyển tư tương duy của lý rằng
kiến tạo môi trường hát triển cho vai nghiệp.
Lông thơi tăng cường giám sát về thực thị trình sách để bỏ đảm các cái cách đi và cuộc sống.
Thông qua đối thại giữa cơ quan phản lý, chuyển ra, dây hội rynh nghiệp và cộng đồng rai nhân.
Hội thảo giữa tối tổng hợp các kiến nghiệp từ thực tiến lựa cơ quan có thông quyền.
Ráp vận hoàn thiện môi trường đầu tư kinh doanh và tạo độ lực mới cho khu vực kinh tế tư nhân trong gia đình hạnh yếu trong ngày sau hành yếu trong mắm bơi.